we are here with Jim Gaffigan how are
you today sir thank you for having me of
course we are surrounded by your face
how awkward but there that's that's you
guys did that on purpose yeah that's
that's one thing so you have two films
at the LA Film Festival
which they could not be more different
movies and I'm wondering what it means
for you personally at this point in your
career to not only be the lead in two
films at this Film Festival vote for
them to be such drastically different
roles and movies it's it's incredibly
exciting I I've always wanted
opportunities that are kind of
exemplified in both these films you know
one obviously to be the lead which is
the you know kind of where you kind of
work every day and you kind of track the
whole kind of meaning of the film but
also the two different roles one which
is I guess a romantic comedy or an
offbeat comedy and one that is a pretty
dark drama it's it's fun I mean you know
like I you know as a comedian I feel as
though comedians are kind of spoiled by
the immediacy to their art like if I
come up with an idea I could go and try
it tonight in the club whereas you know
in acting opportunities like in these
two films it's it's taken 30 years and
they all are they're landing the same
week at the LA Film Festival I don't
know what that means necessarily there
are so many festivals yeah
but I'm I think this is the most
important festival now it's it's
basically the Oscars of them it is and
right and you're in two movies I'm very
excited so I'm gonna start with an
American dreamer because there's such a
departure from what people I think
expect from you just to start off how
you been describing it to people because
it's a little it's a little hard to
describe well it's yeah I I haven't
really had the opportunity to describe
Italy many people but it is I think
story wise it's about someone who kind
of
is trying to find their way through life
and but I think it's indirectly kind of
a commentary on and I'm reluctant to say
this because I want people to get their
own kind of big way but I do feel like
it's a commentary on the entitlement
that some white guys kind of feel
entitled to like this guy is you know he
plays kind of like an uber lyft driver
who's had some bad luck he had the white
collar job and instead of looking at his
own problems he's kind of looking for
that quick fix to get out of it and
that's kind of what motivates him but
it's also a film about just bad decision
making you know yeah and I don't know I
mean I personally haven't seen it I'm
gonna see it okay
Thursday night but you know when you're
the lead of something you you know and
obviously the director was very you know
we communicated a lot about tone and
stuff like that but it would it could
look different you know than what I
thought but it's it's a pretty amazing
opportunity I don't know if I answered a
question well I mean the important thing
about sum is you you kidnap a child yeah
I mean I I'm always reluctant to I'm not
sure if you want people to know that but
yeah well you know the thing is is like
yeah you know I mean it's out there now
but you know this guy is trying to kind
of piece his life together in the
easiest selfish way he doesn't set out
to do that it's not like all the
motivations of my character are not kind
of evil but maybe there are a little
dim-witted but like hopefully you know
you see him justify these actions and
it's not for comedic effect it's for
it's like oh dude don't don't do that
don't do that but you you can see some
of it's in the script
the the reasoning behind his actions so
he doesn't set out to kidnap a child he
doesn't set out to do a lot of the
things he does in the movie and
particularly by the end you realize you
know he didn't have to do any of these
things but he he kind of feels like he
can and he kind of and and and there's
something of I don't want to give away
the ending but there's something to be
said for you know does he get away with
it and why does he get away with it
mm-hmm that's where I think when I talk
about the entitlement thing where you
kind of get a sense of like oh [ __ ] you
know maybe I think he did yeah what
given that it is such a departure for
you and it is such a dark roll what what
jury to but what made you say yeah I'd
like to play this this cab driver exam
says child well I mean I you know
obviously I'm a complex you know person
multi-layered yeah with different shades
I mean I'm mostly pale but so I mean the
more complex the character the more fun
it is as an acting opportunity right but
yeah I mean I you know it's weird
because I think that the entertainment
industry there is something of you got
to show me what you can do so I was
excited to play the role but I was also
excited because as a result of this now
people will see that I can do this I
also understand that you know there are
some comedians that really love acting
and then there's a lot of comedians that
don't care I mean I am one of those that
really enjoys acting so I I like the
opportunity to prove that I can act -
hmm not only is it a dark role but from
what I've seen in it you're playing
occasional you're playing intimidating
which I don't think that is really what
people you know think of
when they think of you but you know
you're you're bigger guy you played you
played football in college did you
always know that you could play
intimidating if you want to do yeah I
mean well you know if my any my children
were here they'd say I'm intimidating it
is weird
it's a perception business we're in
right so you know the fact you mentioned
that I played football in college and
you know I was an athlete but I think
you know because I'm a white bread guy
and maybe I have a whiny Midwestern
voice people assume like people are
always shocked that I'm in real life I'm
actually eight feet tall don't realize
you should see but you know but I'm
actually sitting on the ground right so
that's a lot of actually realize but no
so it is it's a strange journey this
perception business so in some ways you
you can't control it so like
opportunities like American dreamer are
great because you can show a different
size but I mean I don't think I'm the
monster that's portrayed in American
dreamer but I think everyone has a dark
side I mean especially you know like a
very dark side you know right before
this we're gonna find out you're a
murderer Ryan yeah like during is in
yeah you're gonna do it during the
interview you're gonna drag it out of
why is that why you have a chainsaw
okay all right all right fine I mean
it's weird because I'm sitting on the
ground it's gonna be weird
it's me very weird by the way I'm in a
fat suit right a lot of people don't
realize that I'm actually that's why I
show them so early we do put the fat
yeah sure like all this you know it's a
little bit like ooh blah yeah uh moving
on pass that fast you're fats you to
sort of piggyback off of what you were
just saying what's what's something that
you relate to in the character because
it's it's you mentioned you're not this
person but what's something that you
sort of like oh I understand that or I
get that motivation I think that I think
that a lot of men are
you know immature I think that you know
like there's this Ben Folds song still
fighting it which i think is a you know
it's he singing about his son but I
think a lot of men might see it a my my
sons it's like like women are just you
know more equipped for the trials and
tribulations like navigating
disappointment and failure and so
obviously I didn't react like cam did
with some of my failures but I think
that you know getting angry about things
I can't control is absurd but I still
get angry about them and I think that
that's not to say that women don't also
but I think that that that immaturity
like I think men just kind of struggle
to hold it together more it's no mistake
that most serial killers are men mm-hmm
I mean that's just that's just a fact
right you know we're just we're just
these orangutan serial killing right
Angus hands yeah I mean yeah and so it's
not it's not too foreign from who we are
special you I mean it's weird why are
you wearing pants during the inner I
don't ever wear pants okay all right I
just think it's handsome the tits on the
table now chainsaw under the table
skills
under the table when you're doing a role
this dark how do you Jim Gaffigan go to
a dark headspace what is what is your
process - there's a scene where you need
to be especially intimidating a scene
where you need you especially frantic
what do you do to get into that
headspace you know I think it's it's
it's not undifferenced it
you know the rationalization that exists
for every motivation for that character
you kind of justify in your mind and so
some of it is just you know emotional
mathematics in your mind which is
probably dangerous to do where you
justified your horrible behavior but I
mean this movie at one you know American
dreamer at one point was called night
because it's essentially takes place
mm-hmm at night the entire night and
there is something dark about night it
was it was it was a you know it was late
at night we're exhausted it was really
low budget there was you know there was
no trailer here I mean so like there was
like you you know if you found some you
know some space you could kind of sit
and access it very quickly you know like
I mean I remember great people on this
group but like they gave me a room for
though it was kind of my dressing room
and there was no chair or anything so
like to relax i sat on the ground you're
me and which is funny but it's also kind
of like there was something bare-bones
about it there was no luxury hmm which
was great because you kind of use all
that stuff and I also you know I have
you know anger inside of me and
frustration and you know I've murdered
Pete you know I mean who hasn't you know
I mean ants on the table
you forgetting keeping the rules of this
interview at which there are none
because of the movie is such a dis tone
onset where people sort of looking to
you to maybe lighten things up or were
you like hey that's not that's not my
job on this one
it's it's really interesting you bring
that up because I have you know not that
I have a huge library of rules but I
usually play kind of vulnerable
incompetent person and what usually
happens over the course of shooting
whether it's on a TV show or in a movie
the crew will end up treating you like
that yeah they're like you know couply
this
as a loser you're like dude I'm married
to a beautiful woman I'm just playing a
guy who can't get a date so but on this
movie it was interesting because it was
a production that utilized a lot of
people from Old Dominion University like
the theater the film program at the
school was used so there was kind of
this balancing act of college students
who were helping and he wanted to be
like thanks for your help but you also
wanted to be like alright now I'm gonna
go over here and kidnap a kid so it was
a balancing act of but it was a very
small crew and and you know they you
know everyone was there for the right
reason I mean that's on any kind of
acting up have had that that really kind
of determines a lot of the tone is
everyone here for the right reason is if
someone here just as an ego trip or is
someone here just for a paycheck and in
this film and also you know you can
choose your family everyone was there
for the right reason you know it's like
there's not a lot of glamour that's a
great irony of premieres is like you sit
there and everyone kind of like goes on
for hours of sleep and they're freezing
and complaining and they're drinking you
know coffee and eating crappy food and
then at the end a couple months later
everyone dresses up and goes into a
movie theater and acts like they're at
prom it's a strange thing yeah
movies are weird they're weird making
movies is weird so I would I do want to
talk about you can choose your family
which is you know it's a much lighter
movie so much for your movie but you're
still playing and not so good a not so
great guy yeah I'm wondering first of
all how you've been explaining this
movie to people because this is yeah
this is also a very complex story yeah
and if that it was in your mind that
you're moving towards this direction
where you're playing these these not so
spectacular dudes yeah I I mean and you
know I'm not the brightest guy in the
world but like I also feel as though you
want to play someone who is complex
or corrupted or has justified bad
behavior but in you can choose your
family how I describe it is this guy
who's a really strict I play a guy who's
a strict father of a teenage boy in the
early 90s and the teenage boy suddenly
discovers that my character has a
complete second family and it's a comedy
but the weird thing is is that over the
course of the movie you know one of the
things I was trying to do was to build
some not empathy for this guy because
he's guilty yeah
but also some humanity mm-hmm so it's a
human thing because even people that do
horrible things are human and you know
sometimes people make horrible decisions
and they kind of can't find their way
out of it
as opposed to you know cam who makes a
series of bad decisions you can choose
your family you know my character Frank
makes one bad decision and then probably
out of cowardice you know he kind of
explains it that he never got out of it
and and of course the you know the movie
kind of deals with this process of how
it actually brings him closer to his
teenage son it's absurd but it's kind of
a fun ride but you know understandably
today we are in this era where you don't
want to be humanizing horrible behavior
but there is something of like every
story is unique you know everyone's past
you know our you know great-grandparents
probably did horrible things but they're
still our great grandparents hmm and
they're great I'm not saying that's why
they're great because they did horrible
things well it's interesting that you
mention that you want to humanize them
because you couldn't really help like
the character
even though he's blatantly doing one of
the worst things that could happen yeah
I wonder if there's anything specific
you had in mind with how you wanted to
to you know sort of ground him or was it
just sort of an innate thing that came
from your your performance well some of
its I think innate but I think there is
you know some of its just storytelling
you know you see I mean we see it in an
episode or you know a three-block
episode of Game of Thrones you know
suddenly we're rooting for Jaime
Lannister how's that your I mean how did
we pull that off and so some of it is
that's a fun ride and there's some
complexity to it but yeah I don't know I
think you're kind of conscious of it you
know whether you're in the first act or
the last act of a movie you know like I
mean I you know when we were shooting
the initial scene I was definitely not
trying to ham it up but I was much more
of a strict you know father as opposed
to once we're exposed works and all were
inevitably more vulnerable and we can't
I mean the whole role of being a parent
and I've got five kids it is a bit of a
charade mm-hmm deer I mean it's like
there's that sad moment every teenager
realizes whether they like their parents
or not when they realize oh no they
don't know what they're doing at all
yeah and they're just acting like that
and so I think you could choose your
family capture some of that in the
relationship I have with Logan and who's
great in the movie yeah yeah I was
actually gonna mention that you over the
years you have built up this image as
just a family man you have five kids and
it's just it's a subject of your comedy
I'm wondering how that that contributes
to a role where that idea is actively
played against where the the idea of a
family man who on the outside looks like
he has a family but he's really unhappy
and he doesn't really want that I'm
wondering how you thought how your image
connected to that role well you know the
weird thing about the even the image of
you know again this goes back feel like
almost this perception industry we're in
it's not as if you know like i sat there
and i go alright you know what kind of
comedian I'm gonna be I'm gonna be one
that doesn't curse and I guess if I'm
not gonna curse I might as well have a
lot of kids and so it all started with
that yes dear I mean like it wasn't some
tactical move I mean some of it is I
come from a small town in Indiana where
I mean I curse in everyday life you know
I'm not afraid to say [ __ ] [ __ ] it
just doesn't seem necessary if I'm
talking about mini-muffins
yeah do you I mean unless you're just
really matter I mean are you that angry
many muffins but and so like you know
the being this family man which is is in
the most probably the most unsexy thing
you could be it's just a reality I mean
it's like I am conscious of the fact
that being a father is the most
important thing I'll do in my life but
you know you know you know I'm far from
perfect
you know I murdered people we've
established you a serial murder de lot
of and that boom you're eight feet tall
and I'm not wearing pants
yeah so we're not perfect yeah I mean
we're all there's a little bit of Stalin
and all of us I'm joking
that's the quote Jim Crow Stalin Stalin
it's interesting because the the
relationship between I'm sure you know
this very well the relationship between
a father and a son is a very distinct
thing and I'm wondering how you find
that chemistry with with essentially a
stranger with with an actor with on a
film it's you know it is I mean it's
it's so an absurd relationship obviously
but and there's varying forms of it bow
particularly was Logan who is kind of I
would say he has a maturity the irony is
he's the most immature person I know but
he has a confidence and unease
that makes them comfortable with you
know a 12 year old and a you know 20
year old the the that ease made it so
you know over the course of the movie
where we connected and there was a
camaraderie and we could kind of
improvise that was easy at the back end
of the movie but like playing difficult
and and constrained by poor
communication between a father and son
that was something I'm kind of grateful
we shot that at the beginning because we
Logan and I were having so so much fun
and he really is a joy to work with so
it's like I didn't want to appear like I
was acting like I was angry at him you
know I wanted to be angry at him yeah
and I was even though both of these
movies are so completely different they
all really at their core are about
family they're about the importance of
family and I'm wondering for you who is
who has talked about family yeah so much
over your career what it is specifically
about family that is always going to be
so ripe for both drama and comedy well I
think that as humans we tend to forget
this but no matter how successful you
are or whether you struggled in your job
or in whether you're in jail or you're a
murderer like you in the end is the
relationships you have with your
children or your parents I mean those
are probably gonna be the last thoughts
right it's like in the end it's like
that cat's in the cradle song is kind of
something that's kind of important it's
weird I don't think that culturally we
and believe me I'm not sitting there
going live family so important I'm just
saying from my view
in the end that's how things are
evaluated like when you're you know if
you're on your deathbed you're not gonna
be you know your agent might be there
you know but it's probably your wife or
your mother or your children or your
children's children in my case you don't
know you know so it's weird I mean
family is I mean there's nothing more I
mean it's like all of Greek mythology
that's all family isn't it in several
different ways
yeah but you're in these two movies you
have plenty on your slate coming up but
you're still doing staying up comedies
yeah I'm wondering if there's a feeling
you have or how do you know when it's
time to get back on the stage or how do
you know when how do you decide when
it's time to get back up on a stand-up
stage well you know for me you know I
was you know my wife had this brain
tumor like not last April but the April
before and and going through that I you
know I I was faced to deal with this
reality that like oh my gosh I'm gonna
be this single father of five children
and and then thankfully she she you know
came back and everything's okay and so I
think I had I have this you know I
always loved doing stand-up and it is
it's you know in some ways it's my
antidepressant like if I don't do it
people you gotta get my wife like you
got to go onstage but like the fact that
it wasn't there was a possibility that I
wouldn't be able to do it anymore
because you can't tour you know hundred
days a year if you have five young
children the fact that it was like I
have a greater appreciation for it now
but like for me there's not this time
where I stop doing it it's it's kind of
ongoing and you know coming up with a
new joke is incredibly rewarding
you know I have you know this special
that came out in July no bleep but the
the material I'm touring with now is new
but it's just this ongoing thing where I
Pratt it's probably how like like
runners feel about running which
obviously doesn't apply like it's like
they have to do it and so it's just it's
amazing it's like the creative outlet is
in the end it's all about creative
fulfillment and that's why I do think
that these smaller nd films are so fun
because every you know I said before
everyone's there for the right reasons
but it's also having you know executive
produce my own show with my wife and and
written you know episodes of my own show
it's like I've been on the other side so
all I want to do when I'm on a film set
is be the good soldier mmm like identify
what the director and what the producers
want and just not be a headache it's
like because I've had that experience I
know that's a bit of a tangent but with
me yeah finally I just want to ask that
you can choose your family's set in 1992
yeah I'm wondering what you were up to
in 1992 and whether at that point you
pictured your career heading to where
you are today 1992 I had been doing
stand-up for I don't know I guess a year
I mean it's insane
yeah when were you born 1992
unbelievable right so I've got a I've
got a funny story of you want to hear
this very much right so I I was doing
this this benefit show in Philadelphia
for this hospital this and Carole King
was on the show
Carole King's my oldest sister was
obsessed with Carole King and but Carole
King was amazing so I show up at this
fancy event
and I learned later on it's one of the
you know the preeminent social events in
Philly and so I went backstage and there
was a woman there and her she looked
like she was in her 30s early 30s and
she was like oh my gosh I went to the
same College as you and I was like oh
wow that's crazy you went to the same
college and and she said yeah she goes
what year did you graduate and I go well
I'm older but I graduated in 1988 and
she goes oh my gosh that's the year I
was born and now it's like it's like but
you're the same aren't you I'm with the
same age anyway so what was the question
then I didn't answer
what was I do and whether I was Sawyer
so I had I was I was you know the first
couple times I did stand-up I did well
or okay
Mamie meaning the first two times and
then I really struggled like I did not
have a performance background I just
went to a friend's son's Bar Mitzvah and
I was like me and if I had a Bar Mitzvah
you know it's like I would if I had that
confidence at 13 it's why essentially in
1992 I was probably in the first year of
three years of bombing on stage just
trying to find confidence on stage and
figuring out what type of comic I was in
the end that I ended up being the comic
I thought I was at the beginning I made
a full circle and here we are here we
are well thank you so much for kind cue
Bridget you can choose your family
and American dreamer both premiering at
the LA Film Festival and you can put
your pants I'm not going to
don't put your pie I'm not gonna put my
pants on this is the Alex Jones Show
Collider
we're colliding two movies that's a bad
impression of them I think that's about
as good as getting here thank you so
much for coming
hey everybody Mark Ellis here thanks for
watching this episode you want to watch
more then click up here or you can click
right here for more great
content from Collider you haven't
subscribed a Collider video do so right
now and share this Vince
thanks for watching
[Music]